ce que vous dites sur le niveau est tout
à fait juste c'est que on a une baisse
générale qui se constate dans le
secondaire et après on a beaucoup de mal
à le rattraper en licenciant master et
savait qu'à partir du moment où on
diminue les gens du bas qui ont fait
croire que tout le monde peut avoir le
bac général
eh bien on a des populations qui arrive
en licence et qui ne sont pas du tout au
niveau et est malheureusement il ya une
sorte de mensonges qui était
institutionnalisé
on donne le bac à des gens qui sont
méritants qui ont travaillé mais qui
n'ont pas les éléments maîtrise
linguistique autres il ya un nombre de
fautes d'orthographe
kiki faramineux et ensuite ces personnes
là et bien elles ont une licence elles
ont un master mais enfin les lacunes
demeurent
il ya les ont du mal à comprendre
pourquoi il trouve pas un métier
pourquoi sont pas embauchés et c'est
souvent des lacunes qui quelques cumuls
et le problème de l'université vous avez
raison de souligner c'est d'abord et
avant tout un problème de l'école
primaire du collège du lycée et c'est là
que ça se joue parce qu'une fois après à
18 ou 20 ans est très difficile de
rattraper le coup
[Musique]